look at the end of the day um when
you're young and junior in your career
um it's the most confusing exciting
wonderful awful day of your life
right um because now it's you it's it's
it's life it's life's journey right you
work your way up to eighth grade and you
have to start again at ninth grade you
work your way up to
senior and you have to start again as a
freshman when you work way up and you're
great and then now you're
you're nothing again um
but i think uh there are too many
people who graduate school thinking that
they have to have it all figured out on
day one
yes and you don't because there's
something wonderful about being junior
inside a company
right you probably uh
don't have as many um responsibilities
as other people um you may or may not
have a
a spouse you probably don't have kids
the vast majority of people don't have
kids at this time in other words
you can do anything you can go try stuff
out also
your cost of living is a lot lower um
and
um and you can't really break anything
at a company and bring the company down
this is the best like if you're senior
and you make a bad decision
you can break the whole company when
you're junior you make a bad decision
maybe you lose a little bit of money
right um
there's not much you can really do
that'll that'll break the company but
and so this is an amazing opportunity to
practice and learn and practice and
learn
find a mentor and a mentor is not
someone who is your champion who will
put in a good word for you so you get
the promotion right a mentor somebody
who's probably not even
at your company and if they are at your
company they don't have to be in your
chain of command
there's somebody who likes you and you
like them and they believe in you and
they see maybe a little bit of themself
in you and they want to see you do well
and they give you candid and honest
advice in other words come to learn to
come to be
a better version of yourself too many
people start off trying to prove
that they are worthy of being there
trying to prove that they
should be in charge and yet everybody
knows
that you have no experience we know
we store your resume your resume says
your gpa
and what you graduate you have no jobs
right
you wrote it down here cafeteria
is not like the thing we're thinking we
took a bet on you because we liked you
and you're a nice kid and
we tried to form it but we don't know
you got no experience
right so this is the best time to try
things out and experiment
and push the boundaries and make sure
you're making friends and make sure
you're taking care of others and make
sure you find a mentor
um and and and enjoy the journey um
you you if you take that route you're
more likely to be successful than not
i'll give you a personal example i
whenever i would interview when i was
junior
they would always say what are you
looking for and my answer was always the
same
a mentor i'd always say i know it's like
looking for love
but i'm looking for somebody who
hopefully will take me under their wing
and grow me
and i would turn down high profile
amazing jobs to take something that was
kind of rinky dinky
because i liked the person i would be
working for more and i remember working
with colleagues
who all they cared about was the high
profile job with the high paycheck
and they every decision they made was
paycheck which which one's going to pay
me more
i their lives i know what happened to
them because i've stayed in contact with
some of them
they're the unhappiest people i've ever
met they made a lot of money in the
short term
but then they ran out of passion and
they ran out of love and they ran out of
friends
and they their careers went like this
and plateaued
and it's because every decision they
made was money and i you talk about
people who have no
joy in work where the people who try to
make the decisions based on who i work
for
and the kind of work they made less
money in the early days
i'm trying to do it with my hands uh
they made less money in the early days
but then it went like this later on
right
to a t
[Music]